very surprised to read that you're a
Beyonce fan I shouldn't say that I
suppose but you don't seem like your
average Beyonce fan to me I don't know
you don't look like a yeah I'm getting a
country-western vibe from you is that is
that wrong a Conway Twitty you know I
hate Kaiser and his band of renown I
don't know you I'm just not getting a B
it's a very really is that you listen to
Beyonce yeah I do I listen to a bunch of
music
mostly because I have five children who
have a eclectic music interest right and
so they I know Beyonce's work listen to
all of lemonade and it came they
actually came in handy one day I'm
sitting I'm FBI director I'm getting
briefed on a counterintelligence case
and they always have code names and so
the counterintelligence leaders said sir
this is codename sand castles
and I said like the Beyonce song and I'm
looking at a roomful of 20 FBI leaders
and they're all look at me like what you
know we built
whose story talk about the worst show on
television there was dead silence yeah
they all thought I'd lost my mind when I
told my kids that they said yeah dad
they're not as cool that's a fantastic
story I love I love that I love that
you're educating everybody that works in
government
you